this is Bob Edwards at Davos thank you
for asking but that the most interesting
moment today was being asked a question
how do we solve the world's issue around
resource scarcity the reality is that
we've never been at a point in the
history of mankind where there's more
abundance and natural resources and so
is there a bit of a contrarian answer
but that in reality what we find here at
Davos is that people are coming to grips
with them with the fact that it's not
about scarcity it's about abundance it's
about you on the energy side we now have
a hundred year supply of natural gas in
North America around the globe there's
over a hundred year supply of coal in
terms of oil that resources absolutely
abundant the question is what we do with
it responsibly in order to create the
economic outcome for the bottom of the
pyramid in the developing world that
deserves low-cost resources delivered in
a responsible way so that's nation it's
not about scarcity and how we create
create more natural resources how we use
it responsibly to benefit those that
need it the most okay okay